just keep going over and over do as many
variations as you you feel like you wish
to make
yeah keep going do it three if you do it
three if you do three each you know
yeah should
we y
so I'm just going to over talk while you
do it all right so if you keep going so
at this point they
bow they come together do not touch the
K they slide apart but there'll be a
nervousness within them
both and the nervousness will be because
they want to be
correct this is quite a standard but
this also means that they cannot be
massui because they're worrying about
getting it correct but this is what
basic training means it's learning the
form so while we learn the form we will
become
nervous and um in time we must overcome
this so that massui takes place
so that's um an average speed that it
would be done at if you could do it
slower now and show each point as a as a
pause and then carry on to the next one
please
me